hey everyone james murphy here with mcoding. in
this video we're talking about method chaining.
this design pattern is not specific to python
and you may also see it referred to as "method
cascading" or using a "fluent api". here we
have a simple player class. player has a name,
a position, and a level of fatigue. we can draw
players, move players, and let them rest. so
let's create a player. i make a player james
then move him up, right, up, let him rest, and
then draw. there's nothing wrong with doing things
this way and this is how i usually do it ... but
look how much of this code is just repeating the
word "james". this is a verb driven api, move,
rest, and draw all just return none, so how about
instead we make them all return self? then each
of these methods returns the james object back
to me so now i can delete these and do this.
now all the repeated information is gone.
you can put all the calls on separate lines
if you use line continuations, or if you wrap
everything in an extra pair of parens then you
don't need line continuations, and this is the
style i see most common in the wild. just keep
in mind that in order to convert an api into
this form all of the methods had to return none.
this kind of api works because each of these
methods is a verb that mutates the underlying
object. and there's also a variant of this pattern
for immutable objects. you're probably familiar
with the idea even if you haven't explicitly used
it. here i have some random text, then all chained
together i can say take the text, strip it,
uppercase it, and center it. and python strings
are immutable so instead of actually stripping the
string it returns a stripped copy of the string,
and likewise the other methods return some
kind of modified copy of their self parameter.
here's an example how to code a class
with method chaining support using copies.
i've got a basic xyz vector and normalized returns
the same vector but scaled down to unit length.
just compute the length of the vector, then
construct a new object of the same type as self.
of course pass in the modified arguments. and the
same kind of thing goes for a reflected vector.
now we can create a vector 1 2 3 and i can get
a reflected normalized copy. because we made a
copy our p and q are different. if reflected and
normalized modified the original vector and then
returned self, then they would be the same. of
course there's always a penalty if you're making
copies of things but there are also benefits to
making things immutable, so this is a trade-off
that you get to decide. how about a real and
useful example of where this actually shows up?
here i have two sql alchemy database models. my
user model has an id, a name, and a full name.
and the address model has an id, email
address, and the user id that the email
address corresponds to. straight from the docs,
look how we can pick out an email address.
we start with a select address. this creates a
select object. a select object models a select
statement that you're going to send to
the database to get information back.
at any point in the process we can print
the select statement and see the sql that
it corresponds to. so here we have a select id,
email address, user id from the address table.
when i uncomment the join, now i have
join text on the end of the query.
every time i apply another method i get back
another select object with a more detailed query.
this is method chaining at work, and it makes
creating sql queries really easy in python. how
about a data science example? here's some sample
sales data across four different months for three
different companies. using plain old pandas you
might write code that looks something like this.
first we create a data frame object from the
sales data. we don't really care about company
1 so we delete it. we know there are some nans in
there and for this analysis we don't want to use
them so we'll drop them. oh, and these aren't just
company 2 and 3 it's actually amazon and facebook,
so let's rename. and the google data was stored
somewhere else, so let's go ahead and add it in.
then we go ahead and proceed to do whatever data
analysis we were going to do. there's nothing
necessarily wrong with this code, but it's still
kind of just hard to read. enter pyjanitor. it's
a library that you can pip install and it provides
a method chaining verb-based interface to pandas
data frames. now the same operations as before can
be done in a much cleaner and more uniform way.
i hope you can agree that this is a lot
easier to read than the previous example.
i load my dictionary, i remove a column, i drop
the nans, i rename a column, i rename another,
and then i add a column, and that's all there
is to it. it's all the same functions as before
or you can define your own, and it just provides
an easy way to kind of create a pipeline for your
data. if you're an R programmer, then this
should look pretty familiar to you, and the
design of this library was actually inspired by R.
remember, don't ever try to force this into one of
your projects, but do consider it as an option.
that's all i've got, please let me know what do
you think? do you like the way that method
chaining looks? is it more or less readable?
are copies worth it for immutability,
or would you just prefer to avoid it?
let me know with a comment. as always, thank
you to my patrons and donors for supporting me.
if you especially enjoy my videos please
consider becoming a patron on patreon. enjoy
your day coding and don't forget to slap that like
button an odd number of times. see you next time.